Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in the chapter of authored by
he mentions in the first narration of
this chapter
forch.
[Silence]
He says on the authority of
who narrates that it was said, "Oh
messenger of Allah, who are the most
dignified, the most virtuous,
the most meritworthy of people?"
He said,
"Those of them who exhibit the most
tawa."
He was then said,
"Not we did not mean this. We're not
asking about this."
He said,
"Yuf,
the
prophet of Allah, son of the prophet of
Allah, son of the prophet of Allah, son
of the
of Allah." They said, "Neither is this
what we intended with our question." He
said,
Then do you intend to ask me about who
are the most virtuous
from the tribes of the Arabs lineage
wise?
He says the best of them in Jahia are
still the best of them in Islam provided
they understand provided they have
knowledge of the Quran and Sunnah. This
narration has been collected by both
bkari and Muslim. Here Abu narrates that
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam was
asked who is the most virtuous of
people?
Who has the highest merit of people? Who
is most respectable, most dignified,
highest in stature of people?
and who is most esteemed amongst
mankind.
And so in a general sense
it is
the prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
responded saying,
"Generally speaking, those of them who
are most exhibiting of tawa,
those who are most obedient of Allah
with the intention of worshiping
Allah with said obedience. These are the
most virtuous people."
They said, "This is not what we meant.
Meaning the question at first was who is
the most virtuous of people? Of people.
This could be general of all people. It
could be specific
meaning
people of lineage or it could be
specific meaning who are the best of the
tribes of the Arabs which is what he was
what they actually intended by their
question. And this shows us that
we mentioned that half of knowledge is
question. H half of all knowledge is a
question. The other half is answer the
correct answer to that question. And if
a person is unable to
put their question or to get the
knowledge they are seeking with the
question they're unable to put their
ailment
into words in order to ask questions and
and seek that knowledge then the
person's knowledge will be flawed.
One of the things that honestly
is a bit disheartening is
how in a hurry we are to
get things. You know, it's we're a
product of our environment and our
environment is all based on same day
shipping and
get it now. get it immediately. You
don't even need to have money. Just get
it and pay it later. You don't have
money, that's fine. Here's a credit
card, right? We don't have to wait for
anything anymore.
And so this makes its way into
our behavior
in all aspects of our lives. And a
part of that that suffers is our seeking
of knowledge.
asking
a question
that is
not
pondered, that is not properly
worded, that is not properly thought
out.
And the idea is, well, what's the harm?
Right? Oh, there's the she
looks he's not doing anything. let
me just go and and just you know think
of stuff on the fly to ask. This is a
deficient way of seeking knowledge. We
have to
take the time to be deliberate in the
questions and the answer is only going
to be as good as the question is.
If the question is worded properly, if
the question is focused properly, then
the answer will be likewise worded
properly and focused properly. And it
takes time to fashion a question
properly. And a person should always try
to answer the question before they
ask it to themselves. Meaning in order
to ensure that they are getting what
they are seeking.
And so here they asked him a question,
but it was too vague. And so the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
answered based on the way that the
question was worded.
what is meant by
here? And so the original question is
what are the mo who are the most
virtuous of people meaning in all things
in all aspects generally the most
esteemed of mankind. He said and this is
the reason that this narration is in
this chapter.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala answered this
question. He said,
"And second of all, we learn from this
narration that not only do we take the
time to make sure that we word questions
properly, to make sure that we mold
things over, that we think about them,
that we spend time with our questions as
much as we spend time with the with the
answers to those questions." But
furthermore,
we see that the answer itself
needs to not skip over the Quran and
skip over the Sunnah. The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam was asked the
question. The first place he went to
look for the answer was where? In the
Quran. He found the verse that answers
that question. So he didn't say anything
more, anything less. He said exactly
what Allah taught him in the Quran.
And so they said,
"This isn't what we intended by our
question." So he said,
"So now the next the next
the next guess for what it is that they
intend is who is the most virtuous of
people in origins and lineage, right?"
And so
he said Ysef he has the best lineage.
The best lineage.
Does this mean that he is better than
the prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam?
Not in a general sense. But as we
mentioned before, virtues
some
someone less virtuous
may be more virtuous in particular
aspects.
And so Ysef
is most virtuous of mankind in lineage.
Why? The prophet sallall.aii Wasam says
Ysef he is the prophet of Allah. Son of
the prophet of Allah
son of the prophet of Allah is son of
the of Allah Ibraim.
What better lineage than that? Four
generations
of prophets.
They said
this isn't what we intended again.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam now is forced to ask them,
"Are you asking me about the tribes of
the Arabs? Now he's asking them
questions because it's clear that
they're unable to word their question to
get what they what they need.
So instead of just answering, let me
help them
word their question properly. And so now
he's asking qu they came with a
question. Now he's asking them
questions.
Are you asking me about the precious
metals of the Arabs?
and
so a is a precious element, an element,
a precious metal if you will, gold
and silver. And so he says,
, are you asking me about the precious
metals of the Arab tribes, meaning which
tribes are most virtuous? He said, the
most virtuous of them
The most virtuous of them before Islam
are still the most virtuous of them
after Islam
provided they
provided they understand they have
understanding of the Quran and Sunnah.
This is a prerequisite to virtue isn't
it?
Understanding of the Quran and Sunnah.
It's a prerequisite. It's a condition of
virtue, isn't it? Is there any way that
I can be really, really smart or really
have super good intentions and just
stumble my way into virtue?
You know, it's saying,
you know, the Quran and Sunnah,
knowledge of the Quran and Sunnah,
that is where excellence is going to
come from.
If a person doesn't have knowledge of
the Quran and Sunnah, they do not have
the physical or the they do not have the
materials needed, the knowhow needed in
order to reach those excellent levels
even if they want to,
right?
And so knowledge of the Quran and Sunnah
is where is where the details come from.
If you went to
buy a car,
collector, a collector's car, car of a
collector, a very, very expensive nice
car, would you be okay with it being
having a scratch over here, broken
headlight,
missing tires,
details?
The more expensive it is, the more
detail oriented it is. Is that not
correct? That's what knowledge of the
Quran and Sunnah is. This idea that we
don't need knowledge. And we're not
speaking about just general knowledge.
Intimate knowledge of the Quran,
intimate knowledge of the Sunnah,
constantly studying from today until the
day we die in order to reach high levels
with Allah. And all we need is just to
have a good heart and a pure heart and
as long as my intentions are good,
everything will just be okay. And I
don't really need to know all that fancy
stuff. Leave that for the scholars. And
you hear the stories of the the young
man who's pure at heart is more virtuous
than the elderly
scholar who is impure at heart, etc.,
etc. These fables and these fantasies
are killing us.
We have to understand that excellence
and
excellence and knowledge go hand in
hand. You don't find one without the
other.
Excellence and knowledge go hand in
hand. That's why the Quran has been
preserved. Not just for scholars. As a
matter of fact, when did we start to
fall as an ummah? when we relinquish the
Quran to just the scholars say you know
the Quran that's for scholars we're out
here doing the work let the scholars
study the Quran and you know we will
leave them at that and a scholar is only
going to be as good as his
as his people are
and a teacher is only going to be as
good as his students are and so
knowledge of the Quran and Sunnah and
understanding of the Quran and Sunnah is
a pre-erequisite
to excellence. There is no excellence
without that knowledge. That is why
Allah taught us of two types of people
with respect to knowledge
and
aldim.
They are the ones who have knowledge but
do not implement it.
They are the ones who try to implement
without knowledge. We are taught to seek
refuge with Allah and ask Allah to guide
us the opposite of both of those paths.
every single salah, every single think
about that and that is with respect to
people's relationship with knowledge.